in this project we'll be covering
threading using javascript's dedicated
workers
and this will really help with the
hiccups and overall jankiness you might
have seen in previous versions of the
terrain generation code
so just to recap we've been building out
a series on 3d world generation
and procedural terrain in javascript and
3gs
starting with basic mesh generation and
moving on to entire worlds
and advanced texturing techniques let's
take a step back now and work on making
the entire thing a bit faster
because right now it's it's pretty slow
and we'll be using web workers which are
javascript's way of running things in
the background in another thread
off the main execution thread what that
means is we can run the game at full
speed on the main thread
and build the terrain in other threads
in the background without interrupting
or slowing things down
before we begin make sure you're
subscribed to this channel and on
twitter so that you're notified when new
videos are released and you can also get
previews of what's coming up
so this was inspired by another user who
saw my planet generation videos and
built a really cool version using web
workers
i've included the link to their video in
the description
so let's go screw with the code and make
it faster threading or pushing work into
background tasks
isn't intrinsically complicated to
understand we can look at a simple
example of how to do it
here's a little basic chunk of code what
you do is declare a worker like this or
const w equals new worker and worker.js
then to actually do some work you need
to pass data to the worker
and supply a callback for when the
worker responds
something like w dot post message and
you put some parameters in there
and then w dot on message and supply a
callback
now in worker.js we also need to declare
an onmessage handler
and remember this is the code that runs
in the background
here we'll declare an on message handler
check the subject
push a few extra items into the list and
post it back to the main thread using
post message
now let's run this and what you'll see
is the console output has the list of
items one through six
not super exciting but it should help
you begin to understand the
architectural requirements when you
thread things
in general what you need to understand
is that you've got the main execution
thread
imagine it as a single line moving to
the right as time advances
you've got these chunks of work that
take some time let's represent those
with boxes
and so they could be anything in a game
you've got update the ai
that's a box you've got three chunks of
terrain to build those are three boxes
then you've gotta draw everything and
that's a box
in a single threaded context these boxes
all have to be done in sequence
so you do various bits of work you build
those chunks of terrain
then you draw and you repeat it next
frame do some work draw do some work
draw
etc etc in a simplified multi-threaded
context
things are a bit more complicated you
have multiple timelines
or threads where work can be conceivably
done in parallel
so imagine now i have this second line
where work can be done
representing the worker now your first
instinct might be to do something like
this
where you push the work of rebuilding
these chunks to the worker and then wait
till it's done
then draw and that's fine it kind of
works especially if you have lots of
workers
things will definitely go faster than in
the single threaded case
but if some chunk of work takes an
especially long time
what ends up happening is the main
thread ends up waiting around
pointlessly
and the game stalls and feels a little
jerky as it freezes for a bit
a better way to do this is to push the
work to the worker but we don't wait for
it to finish
what we do is we just move on with our
lives at that point and when the worker
is done
it sends the work back and whenever that
happens to be is when we update the
terrain
so let's code this up luckily we didn't
write a mess of spaghetti code last time
responsibility was delegated reasonably
well from the main
terrain class to a builder class and
chunks were encapsulated with the train
chunk class
to thread this it'll require almost no
changes to the original application we
just need to write a
new terrain builder threaded class to
replace the existing terrain builder
and we'll be on our way as a side note
threading is a complicated subject but
taking a bit of time to use good
software design practices
made injecting it into our code really
easy let's take a quick look at the
original
single threaded terrain builder class
you can see here
the public api isn't that extensive you
have an allocate chunk function which
just creates a new chunk of train
you've got this busy property that
signals the builder is busy at the
moment and can't take
new requests a rebuild function which is
a request to rebuild these particular
chunks
and an update function which is called
once per frame to do whatever work and
bookkeeping needs to be done
let's go and thread this thing the first
thing we want to do is make the worker
interface a bit friendlier
we'll start by making our own worker
class that wraps the built-in worker
we'll extend it by adding an id and the
reason we're doing this is because it'll
make it really easy to make a worker
pool
that sends work back to the next free
worker
there's also an on message which just
wraps their workers on message and calls
whatever callback was saved for this
work item
and a post message which saves a
callback and then posts a message to the
worker
they're mostly just wrapper code so now
we'll make this worker pool
and it has to instantiate an array of
workers which is what we do to begin
now the whole point of the worker pool
will be to make it easy to send some
work to the pool
which will then delegate it to the first
available worker
so we keep track of who's busy and who's
free when we start of course
every worker is free now we have this in
queue function
and this is only a couple lines its
responsibility
is to shove the work into a queue and
then it calls pump q
which is the real workhorse of the class
so let's go look at what that does
pump queue is a little complex but at a
high level what it's doing
is whenever there's work to be done it
takes the next free worker
see this line here where it pops it off
the free list and then marks it as busy
then we take the next work item and send
it to the worker
the call back in here since the work is
now complete it removes that work from
the busy list and reinserts it into the
free list
then the callback associated with the
work item is called and we pump the
queue again
let's build out the threaded terrain
generator now
we'll start by making a terrain chunk
rebuilder
threaded class to replace the existing
one
in the constructor here we'll allocate a
worker pool
where we'll be sending all the actual
chunk building to get done
now we'll need to swap out the
implementation starting with allocate
chunk what we do here is we create a
chunk and hide it immediately
like before then what we're going to do
is send a message to our pool of workers
saying we've got a new chunk
here are the parameters we also supply a
callback here which is called when the
worker
successfully builds the chunk and sends
it back at this point onresult is called
and we pass the data to the chunk with
this rebuild mesh from data function
which is mostly responsible for passing
the data along to 3.js and webgl you can
see here all it's doing is passing the
pointers directly to those set attribute
calls
the busy function doesn't change much
instead of checking locally if it's
building something
the threaded version just checks if the
worker pool is busy or idle in the
rebuild function
this is responsible for taking a list of
chunks and cueing them up to be rebuilt
this is super easy here all we need to
do is pass these directly to the worker
pool
finally in update whenever the work is
complete we just hide the old
chunks that's it it's not really much to
do here let's take a look inside the
actual worker code
so that's all in
terrainbuilderthreadedworker.js
down here in the on message function we
just check the subject to make sure it's
about
rebuilding chunks now since that's all
we do in this app it will always pass
but you could conceivably have different
messages handled here
kind of like this we call chunk.init
with the parameters from the message and
call rebuild and post it back
most of this code should look pretty
familiar since it's basically just a
copy paste of the old terrain chunk
class
but there's a few small changes that
need to be made to support the workers
notice the chunk.init call you can't
pass actual instances of classes through
to the worker
so what we do here is in the init call
you can see we've passed the parameters
that were used to instantiate the noise
and other helper functions and now we
instantiate them here instead
looking back at the terrain class you
can see that i've left the old lines of
code here
it used to instantiate the noise and
everything and then pass those instances
as parameters to create chunks but with
a worker you can't pass an instance of a
class
i mean you you could probably do
something smart here but that just seems
like wasted effort
we'll pass the original parameters
instead like we do here
anyway the rebuild function is a
near-exact copy paste of the original
terrain chunk build function
but instead of being a generator we
remove all the yields that were
sprinkled throughout and just
straight up do all the calculations at
the end we use another trick to speed
things up
we could just straight up send the data
across and then upload it
we've still saved all that time
computing but we're going to be using
shared array buffer instead
now a quick aside shared array buffer is
pretty sweet
what it allows you to do is create a
memory buffer that's shared between both
threads
meaning you don't need to copy the data
between the worker thread and the main
thread
instead if you instantiate these shared
array buffer instances
which is what these new shared array
buffer calls do
and you pass the length of the buffer
you need and remember these are byte
arrays so you need to multiply by the
size of a float which is four bytes
what happens is that you write into them
which is what we're doing with these
lines of code here we're copying all of
the generated mesh data
into these shared array buffer instances
and then you pass these back to the main
thread by a post message
when you do that you avoid a whole bunch
of extraneous copies
and that's it once you've done all that
you can load up the planet and see the
smoothness that you've created
as i move around you don't see that kind
of janky smooth and freeze crap that you
saw with the old one
even with all the effort to use
generators it wasn't smooth
but as i zoom in and out move around
everything is totally seamless
let's put them side by side and you can
see that the old one is pretty bad
first of all it takes forever to load
let's just sit here and wait for it
there we go that took a little while and
now let's try moving around
you can see it hanging up all the time
compare that with the left side of the
screen
if we restart you can see it loads up
super fast
all the chunks coming in quickly while
the right side seems to be sitting on
his ass doing nothing
when you move around it's all smooth
nothing freezes
there's no sort of jerkiness to it it's
all good and that's because we're using
the full power of my computer at this
point
i have eight cores in this desktop so
i'm able to build the terrain
significantly faster than in the single
threaded version
i hope you enjoyed this if you haven't
already subscribe both here and on
twitter
you'll get notifications for when new
videos drop and previews on what's
coming up next
i also chat with people and try to get a
sense of what you all want to see next
make sure to like the video and leave a
comment on what you want to see covered
in a future tutorial
the code is all up on github so knock
yourself out
like always do whatever you want with it
doesn't matter
free to use and if you don't understand
anything just ask me
cheers everyone